[Music]
this universality which the individual
of such attains is pure being yet it is
a state which has been reached
immediately in the course of nature not
the result of an action consciously done
the duty of the member of a family is on
that account to add to this aspect in
order that the individuals ultimate
being - shall not belong solely to
nature and remain something irrational
but shall be something done and the
right of consciousness be asserted in it
or rather the meaning of the action is
that because in truth the calm and
universality of a self-conscious being
do not belong to nature you lose the
reappearance that the depth of the
individual results from a conscious
action on the part of nature may be
dispelled and the truth established what
nature did in the individual is that
aspect in which is development into a
universal is exhibited of the movement
of an immediate existent this movement
Falls it is true within the ethical
community and has this for its end death
is the fulfillment and the supreme work
which the individual is such undertakes
on its behalf but insofar as he has sent
it is essentially a particular
individual it is an accident that his
death was directly connected with his
work for the universal and was the
result of it partly because if his death
was such a result it is a natural
negativity and movement to the
individualism your existence in which
consciousness does not return into
itself and become self consciousness or
partly because since the movement of
what merely exists consistent it's being
superseded and becoming a being for some
death is the sign of direction in which
the attained being for self is something
other than the mere existent which began
the movement becomes the ethical order
is spirit in its immediate truth the
signs into which its consciousness
sandra's itself also fall into this form
of immediacy an individuality passes
over into this abstract negativity which
being in its own self without
consolation and reconciliation must
receive them essentially through a real
and external act blong relationships
implements that in the abstract natural
process by adding to it the movement of
consciousness interrupting the work of
nature and rest during the blood
inhalation from destruction or better
because destruction is necessary the
passage of the blood relation into mere
being it takes on itself the act of
destruction through this it comes about
that the dead the universal being
becomes a being that has returned into
itself of being for self or the
powerless simply isolated individual has
been raised to universal individuality
the dead individual by having liberated
his being from his action or his
negative unity is an empty singular
merely a passive being for another at
the mercy of every lower irrational
individuality and the forces of abstract
material elements all of which are now
more powerful than himself the former on
account of the life they possess the
latter on account of their negative
nature the family keeps away from the
dead this dishonouring at him by
unconscious appetites and abstract
entities and puts its own action in
their place and whether the blood
relation to the bosom of the earth to
the elemental imperishable individuality
the family thereby makes him a member of
a community which prevails over and
holds under control the forces of
particular material elements and the
lower forms of life which sought to
unloose themselves against him and to
destroy
this quite long paragraph 452 involves
an analysis of the role and you might
say the options for death what death
means what it turns into
for the the family member understood
as an individual who has died we saw in
the previous paragraph Hegel finishing
things up by suggesting that an
individual really only attains a certain
mode of universality when their life has
come to a finish and he doesn't explore
that all that much in that paragraph
here he he's also not exploring that
thing that notion in terms of say legacy
or the agency of the the person who has
died instead he is interested primarily
in the agency of the blood relative the
member of the family who is living and
we're going to see this play itself out
in the paragraphs yet to come for for
this we're looking at the dead person
you might say almost is the patient in
the in the classical term not in the
medical term the person who is
undergoing the person who is suffering
who is having something imposed upon
them or provided to them so let's see
what he has to say here is there's an
awful lot he says this universality
which the individual is such attained is
pure being that now that's a very
interesting thing to point out people
often ask what is Hegel's doctrine of
being or Hegel's position on being and
Hegel's consistent view is that when
we're talking about being and contre
distinction to say spirit what we're
talking about is something that you know
is is right it's being but it's in an
impoverished way and death you might say
well that's the cessation of being or
that's non being well not completely
it's the end of living being it's the
end of this whole process that we call
life
but it isn't just the end of being per
se there's a lot more that can be said
about this
I'll just suggest that you know when
we're talking about pure being for Hegel
we're not talking about getting to
something that is you know really at the
core of things he doesn't build on a
foundation of pure being rather it's the
higher infuses you might say the lower
or drags it in that's part of what the
whole process of sublation and the
dialectic is about so he goes on and he
says this is the state which has been
reached immediately in the course of
nature now why does he bring up nature
here well because we do exist in a
natural world and when a person dies you
know there's a lot of things we can
introduce as sort of meditations upon
this is the nature and our cultural
attitudes and our own experiences with
death when a person dies there is indeed
a natural process it could be very
abrupt
you know somebody is stabbed or they
they fall and and and you know they
break their neck or all sorts of things
like that or it might be a very long
illness it could be you know an accident
occurs and they bleed out but it takes
you know the course of over a day and
they're in quite a bit of pain usually
as that occurs you know if you think
about the ways in which human bodies can
die and they are quite literally myriads
in the sense of you know thousands you
know so there are a lot of natural
processes and we often think of death as
you know the body returning to its
elements is sometimes how how its framed
so there is this aspect to death right
but then what about when we're talking
about the death of a person an
individual he says you know it's a state
that's been reached in the course of
nature not as a result of an action
consciously done the duty of the member
of a family is on
that account to add this aspect in order
that the individuals ultimate being -
shall not belong solely to nature and
remain something irrational but shall be
something done and the right of
consciousness be asserted in it so
there's a lot that that was just said
there the family member now Hegel's not
saying that this is something that is
universally practiced that everybody
does this some people die you know with
without the possibility of this either
because they die apart from their family
or because their family aren't the kind
of people who would actually recognize
this as that as it's not just a duty but
it's something that that's good
something that that realizes who and
what they themselves are in relation to
the other the family members purpose in
this is to keep this from being merely a
natural occurrence you might say to keep
nature from swallowing up the personhood
of the individual we'll talk about
examples of how that that occurs a
little bit further on in so he says or
rather the meaning of the action is that
the cousin truth the calm and
universality of a self-conscious being
do not belong to nature that's an
interesting thing the calm and
universality of the self-conscious being
as the dead does not belong to nature
nature already is not the totality of
what is for somebody like Hegel it
doesn't mean that there's a radical
dualism here between spirit and nature
or culture and nature or body and soul
or any of these sorts of things
nature matters the natural world is it's
where we move around and negotiate and
live and die but it's not all there is
and it's not all there is either in the
sense of well they're just like a little
residue and the natural world is the
most
of what there is no the natural world is
taken up into the gas tiga felt the
world of spirits so he co goes on and he
says the illusory appearance that the
death of the individual results from a
conscious action on the part of nature
may be dispelled and the truth
established though there is no
consciousness involved in natural
processes right they just are with the
art so he goes on and he says what
nature did in the individual is that
aspect in which his development into
universal is exhibited as the movement
of an immediate existent this movement
Falls it is true within the ethical
community and has this for its end so
already were there's an elevation out of
nature the person is dying a natural
process they are dying within nature as
a person with a body and even in mind
that is in large respect Hegel has no
problem saying this in large respect
their brain but not just that right and
so the ethical community gets brought up
here and the ethical community is
already something where we're moving
beyond mere nature so what is going on
here he says this movement falls within
the ethical community it has it this for
a tenth death is the fulfillment and the
supreme work which the individual as
such undertakes on its behalf so insofar
as the individual is dying they are in a
certain respect in in relation to their
ethical community and the ethical
community here is not the family as such
although the family has an ethical
dimension as we've just seen instead the
ethical community is the the folk the
people the community or the state or
however we want to understand something
more public now how does your death or
the death of your loved one or the death
of somebody that you don't know how does
that fit in with
the ethical community well could we
could think of a number of different
ways Hegel is not spelling that out at
this point and the example that he's
going to use a little bit later is going
to be kind of a strange one but we might
think of you know so death is the
culmination of your life the finish
point what in the course of your life
did you contribute to that ethical
community you probably contributed labor
as a matter of fact you almost
definitely contributed labor of one form
or another you also transmitted meaning
you also probably were involved for
better for worse in the process of
bringing up the next generation and
preparing for things those are just a
few possible examples so again he goes
on and he says here we go insofar as
he's essentially a particular individual
not just understood as this person who's
a member of the community but as a
particular individual somebody who
matters on their own accounts it is an
accident that his death was directly
connected with his work for the
universal and was the result of it
why Hegel tells us partly because if his
death was such a result it is the Nate
the natural negativity and movement of
the individual as a mere existence in
which consciousness does not return to
itself and become self consciousness so
when we're thinking about individuals
and we adopt the sort of you know
top-down perspective what we call a
third-person perspective we're looking
at them from the outside we can't see
although we sometimes do judge you know
structures of motivation we can't
actually see what's going on in their
own relation to themselves how they
understand their identity it's kind of
funny because we we talk an awful lot
about people's identity and we love to
explore that in you know artsy ways in
radio shows and podcasts and works of
art and stuff like that and that's
almost always some you know some person
who
you know is supposed to stand in as a
token for a whole bunch of other people
and be an individual I mean there's a
lot that could be said along those lines
Hegel's point here is insofar as were
just considering the person as a member
of the ethical community we're not
actually thinking about them as a
particular individual it's the family
that's going to restore that why aren't
we because we're not grasping them as
self consciousness we're grasping them
as consciousness so he goes on and he
says insofar as he's essentially a
particular individual it was an accident
right that his death was was connected
with his work for the universal and so
he goes on and he also says if his death
was such a result it is the natural
negativity in the movement of the
individuals marry existent right in
which consciousness is not returned to
itself or partly because since the
movement of what merely exists
consistent it being suspended in
becoming a being for self death is the
side of direction in which the attained
being for self is something other than
the mere existent which began the
movement what is it to be a particular
individual it is not just to remain a
being in itself or a being for other a
being for the community
it is to be being for self how do we
attain that this is a central question
in human development how do we become
beings who are self consciousness in and
for themselves Hegel is addressing part
of the question here not in terms of the
living being except insofar as the
living being as the family member who's
doing something but in terms of the
family member who has died how do the
dead have being for self how are the
dead continued consciousness
how are the dead who they were
this is this is a really central and and
quite you know often mysterious question
henkle is touching on something here
that takes us to the very cusp of an
experience that we cannot escape because
mortality is inescapable not only our
mortality our own being for for death as
Heidegger calls it right but even more
so that of the other the other who is
going to die eventually and we're going
to have to come to terms with that death
or who has already died by the time that
we come on the scene if we're a member
of a long-standing family there are
relatives that we we know in a certain
sense who have long since passed on and
we might extend this to other things
besides the family as well we could
think of you know spiritual communities
we could think of you know what goes on
say in intentional communities such as
monasteries we can think of schools of
philosophy we could we can think of all
sorts of very interesting continuities
in this respect so going on Hegel says
here we go because the ethical order is
spirit in its immediate truth decides
into which its consciousness sunders
itself also fall into this form of
immediacy an individual individuality
passes over into this abstract
negativity which being in its own self
without consolation and reconciliation
must receive them essentially through a
real and external act alright what is he
saying there the ethical order is spirit
in its immediate truth the sides sunder
themselves into immediacy and abstract
negativity the abstract negativity of
the dead individual lacks consolation
and reconciliation it cannot provide it
to itself at the ethical community is
not providing it to it either it must
get it from somewhere else where will it
get it from the family members so Hegel
says blood relationship supplement then
the abstract natural
by adding to it the movement of
consciousness it interrupts the work of
nature it interrupts the natural
processes how do we do this well think
for example this is going to be a
you-know-what Hegel's ultimately talking
about about our funerary rites and the
fact that we mark out space and indeed
time we carve out pieces for our dead
relatives and then perhaps have rituals
you know we have Memorial Day here in
the West you know in some cultures there
are grave cleaning ceremonies and all of
those are occasions not just to go and
get some some ritual out of the way but
to once again recall and perhaps even
commune with the dead relatives to
provide them with what they don't have
in the present we we the living lend
them our our capacities for self
consciousness
you might say from the Hegelian
perspective alright so he Co goes on and
he says we interrupt the work of nature
and we rescue the blood relation from
destruction or better because
destruction is necessary destruction in
some sense right the passage of the
blood relation into mere being it takes
on itself the act of destruction through
this it comes about that the dead the
universal being becomes a being that has
returned into itself a being for self or
the powerless simply isolated individual
has been raised to Universal
individuality we the living again we in
the living give the dead the power that
they have for better or for worse this
is kind of a double edged sword and
Hegel's not really concerned with
analysing that aspect of it but we could
certainly think about this
how the you know the dead retain their
grasp
over the living when it's really just
the living you know continuing on this
is one of the fundamental insights of
you know anthropological theories about
about what human cultures do Marx has a
very interesting discussion of this sort
of thing in terms of capital and its
capacity for extracting labor and how
dead labor is used to you know grasp
living labor you know Freudian depth
psychology and others following in its
wake have other similar things to say
about this we could go on and on any in
any case coming back to this so he says
the dead individual by having liberated
his being from his action or his
negative unity is an empty singular
merely a passive being for another at
the mercy at the mercy of every lower
irrational individuality and the forces
of abstract material elements all of
which are now more powerful than himself
why the former on account of the life
they possess the latter on account of
their negative nature so let's talk
about this let's talk about the latter
which is nature the dead considered
solely in terms of their relation with
nature is being consumed by nature right
and you can see this even with say
gravestones right you take your dead
person and you embalm their body stick
them in a coffin put them in a grave put
a headstone up there and if nobody
maintains that sort of stuff it may take
quite a while I mean some people go so
far as concrete vaults you know because
we have this is worried about corruption
corruption is simply nature taking back
the body which came from it in the first
place through a whole variety of
processes most of which seem to involve
bacteria of one form or another
right we could we could go on and on
with this nature will take
the dead person and consume it because
that's the way it works what is he
talking about with any individuality
he says the dead individual right is at
the mercy of every lower irrational
individuality what would that be well
think about your estate you know there's
some wonderful biblical passages about
you know the the foolishness of the
person who Labor's their entire life and
that is just going to pass on those
things to some schmuck who will do
whatever the hell they want with them
and we can say similar things about
people who are more conscious in their
willing or their legacies it can always
be turned to something that you did not
want your your individuality can be
turned into something quite different
you can become a bad guy in somebody's
history book because the intellectual
fashions of the time have now a
narrative in which the good deeds that
you did are actually tainted by all
sorts of bad characteristics that you
have by belonging to the culture of your
time you know prime example Aristotle
right Aristotle defended slavery well he
only defended a certain kind of slavery
and actually critiqued other kinds and
provided us with you know some good good
criteria for saying why a lot of people
shouldn't be slaves but he did defend it
and so therefore Aristotle is a bad guy
you know who the sort of thing that that
happens Hegel would call that being at
the prey of lesser but living
individuality and there's many many
other ways in which which this sort of
can go on as a matter of fact you might
say that this is even part of the
process not the natural process but the
the spiritual process by which the dead
are continued on and gradually disappear
into being just a figment of somebody
else's imagination or part of their
their their own story or being turned
into props Hegel doesn't think that this
has to be what has on so you know he
says the family keeps away from the dead
this dishonouring of him by unconscious
appetites and abstract entities how does
it do that it puts its own action in
their place
when's the blood relation to the bosom
of the earth to the elemental
imperishable individuality they bury
them right and it could be a burial it
could be setting them out to sea it
could be cremation it could be putting
them in the tower and letting the birds
of the air devoured it could be all
sorts of things funeral rites
there are probably rituals associated
with us as well and mind sets you know
sometimes the period of mourning would
be would be part of this as well which
can go on for quite long
notice what Hegel says this does the
family thereby makes him a member of a
community which prevails over and holds
under control the forces of a particular
material element and the lower forms of
life which sought to unloose themselves
against him and to destroy him the
family keeps the good family the the
working family doesn't keep the person
alive right it it's a misnomer a bit
sometimes we we can call people after
death of a loved one and we say oh well
they live on in our memories Hegel would
say well they live on our memories they
live on as a dead person in our memories
and that's not quite what he has in mind
there is death here but the family
maintains the universality maintains the
be
maintains the personhood of the loved
dead person loved not in the sense of
natural affection or you know something
like that but loving in the in the terms
of action in terms of doing what is for
their good this is do something good for
the dead person but dead who do not
enjoy the blood relations and the family
who died you know orphaned and alone or
shipwrecked are not afforded this sort
of of continuance and protection
you